[Aplausos]
[Música]
igual
sou macho
cansan
tudo era o contrário
[Música]
o senhor acha
pensando acho um ano
acho que vem
[Música]
a empresa
o fez
pilotos santo vai jogar tão pouco
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
essa é a magia da publicidade não fui eu
fiz isto mas esta é a visão que os
brasileiros está em portugal esta
publicidade foi feita por uma empresa
brasileira
inspirada por um brasil edson souza
mendonça que é uma muito conhecido no
brasil e que fez por exemplo a campanha
das eleições para a eleição do
presidente ou a indústria que vem é uma
edição da campanha do presidente ou
naquela altura é o único a 77
isto é ver que as poucas pessoas que têm
uma visão sobre o portugal tem sobre o
nosso país
esta visão estereotipada agora vou me
meter em da água que está a estabelecer
essas coisas
como é que um ponto de inflexão no
estudo
a primeira é que nós somos capazes de
comprar as tragédias aquilo que não
compraríamos a portuguesa não é qualquer
um que está com a seleção brasileira o
trabalho no brasil muito cedo ontem
imensos pai natal mesmo porque eu pensei
por que o povo mas avisam que está em
nós é esta se colocar e vendeu esta
coisa é uma empresa importantíssima do
país ea empresa comprou o que é mais
surpreendente porém não é isso é que
esta publicidade mais recordava do país
ouça as vezes no estereótipo alma vai lá
e há uma verdade encerrada nesta
publicidade
ela pode ser infeliz nesta sala
provavelmente ninguém se identifica com
ela mas ela é uma barraca é que isto é
alma daquilo que nós somos
e eu garantimos uma coisa passa enviar
mais de 80 horas no meio da fila do
norte o sul faz publicidade na américa
do norte para a própria o público
hispânico no méxico no face não fazem as
empresas gastaram no brasil no uruguai
no chile não seguir os animais eo tango
de que os povos um trabalho uma visão
tão estereotipada quanto à lusa
a bolsa está em portugal mas há uma
coisa muito curiosa
é o tal como duda mendonça daniel êxito
naqueles países porque o rio enviou
praianos aquilo que o sal mas que os han
[ __ ] aceitar que são isto é o que nós
somos nós somos o cristo e que copiamos
do cristo redentor uma espécie de retro
colonialismo extraordinário
nós somos um homem do chapéu palha com
uma vara olhar o mal um marco ao ver
dois temas e vincular um pouco mais de
vôo
somos uma banda ao contrário porque a
maioria dos portugueses não sabe
desenhar a bandeira nacional
nós somos isto nós somos isto
e quando nos vemos no ar é claro com
toques em samba não vai à tristeza
manter se na mensagem
quando nos vemos no ar identificamos
tanto que não nos esquecemos aquilo que
os outros é dez em cada cem portugueses
quando se perguntou viu publicidade
ontem respondem sim publicidade viu e
via publicidade do pingo doce do que se
lembra pingo doce vai em é k
bom eu tenho uma visão do país que é uma
grande festa e todos nós todos nós temos
discreto esta escrita conta que tem que
mudar alguma coisa para inventar o nosso
país é para nós temos que encontrar
morrer pra não sair
já houve aqui dizer às novas tecnologias
vamos transformar e talvez papel
higiénico preto aliás extraordinário
porque hoje é que o publicitário foi que
o paulo é um sonho que também sabe isso
há alguns anos e é extraordinário porque
eu não não está contra mas o que ontem
em uma agência de publicidade e pintura
caso tem papel higiênico
eu vivi fizesse qualquer outra coisa e
aplicar essa qualquer outra coisa essa
criança virá a emissão de papéis ou de
papel industrial e eu no papel do
publicitário é o verdadeiro inventor
inovador credor e outro facto penso não
sei se é possível que nós não precisamos
precisamos reinventar que há três dias
atrás tive um princípio não se chama
colônia sacramento que é uma cidade no
sul do uruguai que é uma cidade
portuguesa no sul do uruguai e os
relatores
nós vamos ter o que fazer no uruguai mas
a abstenção foi do brasil e está a fazer
os três chegaram aqui é impressionante
só a 23 no mundo dois têm presença nos
cinco continentes
são os estados unidos têm cemitérios
soldados americanos em todos os
continentes ea um segundo país
nós nem sequer entravam nos nossos
soldados provavelmente por lá ficavam
nos braços algo negativo e foi assunto à
ilha mas é provável é que só há outro
país que espalhou é que os padrões
estava em nós estávamos a escola
primária é como eu tenho seguido pela
esad pelo som que se encontra no centro
do japão pensei comigo é paulo azi a
macau que modo toda é costa indiana
mystery tour luz cai em cima as
fortalezas hoje lido e é menino do
bairro
toda a costa africana né abri lá em cima
nos estados unidos da américa do sul o
brasil
nós não precisamos reinventar
nós só precisamos de encontrar em nós
aquilo que nós é verdadeiramente somos
um povo profundamente trabalhador
profundamente capaz profundamente
honesto que se entregam a qualquer
tarefa com uma dedicação e uma alma como
rara entre isso nós conseguimos
transformarmos nesta coisa que esta
campanha do piloto mas é melhor ao
estereótipo tarde a substância daquilo
que somos nós podemos voltar a ser é que
nunca deixarmos de ser e eu vou estar
aqui quatro exemplos do que vocês não se
dão conta que são altamente controverso
de dizer que seu trabalho por uma das
empresas depositaram e que de fato dizem
que nós podemos ter uma presença no
mundo provém da presença de dodô paulo
em todas as casas do universo e são
quatro empresas que nos transportam e
que nós que criamos não acreditamos
nelas porque está lá uma tala antônio
inicia outra família os pilotos ganham
uma fortuna e não sei que tem a galera
mas existem existem são as nossas
bandeiras da nossa presença cada vez
criado pelo brasil
exemplo aeroporto guarulhos instalar o
avião já estava à minha espera o nt
naquele avião e os sinto em casa
mas foi a casa pretende não só tenho
publica hoje um artigo no expresso que
eu assino com o título merece aplausos
filhos a dois países no mundo
já sabemos casas ou dois que estão nos
cinco continentes e os estados unidos ou
de portugal a dois países do mundo que
tem uma dimensão muito semelhante à
nossa e outros dois que também atraem e
que os escolheram a via das empresas e
outros escolheram outra coisa qualquer e
falharam os que chegaram foram bélgica e
áustria que tenha uma série de coisas e
deixaram terá áustria cedo no periósteo
longa the town desapareceu completamente
falso que nunca assinei verdadeiramente
escolas e nada mas ninguém nem uma linha
aérea e tem não tem nada
essa é da europa que se não é nova
portanto é já vemos o que rola né
há dois outros países que contrapõe
estes que têm dimensões semelhantes
um é suíça e outro ao lado da silva 31
anos vão dizer sei lá e como é que esses
tamancos e não sei que isso vai falar do
banco no segmento obviamente esse feito
não só isso
especializou se em duas indústrias em
que têm uma presença fortíssima
movimentar e vaca e outra indústria
farmacêutica em física simples honesto é
são 100 bilhões de euros de vendas mas é
um país altamente especializados ele é
presença da suíça no mundo faça
exclusivamente através das suas empresas
é neutra não tenha força política não
existe fala cinco idiomas em si como
nação não se sente mas a suíça está na
vida todos nós todos disso
outro exemplo é a holanda arrebanhando
exemplos de empresas holandesas que são
celebradas a fala de zeu exatamente o
papel da atriz ea outra como muito vai
outra unilever próprio viram quantas
empresas talvez conhecem
o lume as aulas o verbo e já foi
vocalista quantas empresas austríacas
conhecem é algo muito vai ser um gajo do
livro que fundou há aqui um problema que
é uma maravilha agora é nós temos quatro
empresas que podiam apresentar para nós
um veículo postura e vou terminar meu
pensamento é tatu está precisando e as a
tam e à tarde não interessa agora são
famílias sabiamente a câmera dessas
coisas vão tocar com vocês grandes de
dinheiro
vou falar com você e eu quem a presença
do país do mundo se unir essas duas
empresas seria maior empresa aérea do
hemisfério sul e para o hemisfério sul
um gigante com cerca de 15 a 16 mil
milhões de euros de facturação só
brincadeira dos professores conquistou
portugal nos calarmos pessoas todos os
percalços na audiência tem muito apreço
por ele vai estar sendo 460 milhões de
euros por ano só para fazer várias
pessoas
com isto mais do que em viabilizar vamos
aonde quatro ou cinco anos por exemplo é
a criação de uma das maiores linhas
aéreas do mundo e que reúne associados
moreno novamente o que é portugal irá da
língua sobre o exemplo é dp e depois já
sabem qual o país do mundo em produção
de energia eólica na relação com aquilo
que é o seu consumo de energia portanto
a defesa teve aqui um trabalho notável
dessa esqueçam lá está o dono inicia não
está lá estão essas pessoas nesta eu não
tenho uma participação do grupo espírito
santo está para lá da controversa estou
a falar da empresa empresa vai
sobreviver e estas pessoas não é
portanto vou falar daquilo que é um
patrimônio que é um patrimônio nosso
país continuar a fazer aquilo que tem
feito até hoje está ótimo
comprou parte aqui outra ali presentes
que não surgirá alteração nenhuma só
pensa que por favor ninguém está recluso
como aconteceu com as importa que era um
dos grandes fabricantes de cimento do
mundo e agora de repente aquilo lá se
foi o controlo pronto com todo mérito
daquilo que são os mecanismos os
mecanismos capitalistas da compra e
venda não sei quê
mas a verdade é que aquilo é uma jóia
que deve ser
nada pro país não sei por que meu nome é
70 propriedades mas interessam em se
manter aquela empresa que a ocb
segundo a empresa já tem 16 painéis
estados unidos têm presença no brasil
vai ter em breve presença na escócia só
pra vocês sancionar o maior produtor de
leite do mundo é f que tem um fator
sazonal cerca de 60 mil milhões de euros
é é bem depende nos 14 mil mestres com
carinho sorte não é uma coisa assim tão
um salto tão grande para nós pensarmos
que o mais viável a quem é que não é
viável e pode ser uma das grandes e
inovadoras empresas na área da produção
de energia a descer empresa ea petrogal
robert maxwell é para toda a gente já
sabe que evitará o grupo amorim essas
questões mas ela vai assim nós temos
ligações históricas outros países o
brasil e angola que tem lá um nome de
petróleo torna que nunca mais acaba
quando a quebra quando chegamos o pitboy
vamos começar a produzir em grande força
nós não temos muito a ensinar
neozelandês certamente nem os ambulantes
no que é produção e extração de petróleo
mas se nós nos juntarmos a elas damos
acesso ao mercado europeu é através de
uma distribuição generosa já temos em
portugal a espanha tenta trocar um
movimento legal e que certamente presos
têm muito valor porque eles são
produtores astra comunitários fora da
união e portanto seria um acesso a este
é isso daí estes 300 poderia dar muito
mais 14 exemplo mencionado antes o que
você quer dizer os povos são no fundo é
o estereótipo ea substância por trás do
estereótipo nós ainda temos esta
presença no mundo só vos peço que quando
a próxima vez que falarem da tábua e dos
pilotos e daquelas plantas muito
antipática às pessoas um sentido
com freqüência as vivências delas do
quero pensar não quero nem eu sei porque
tem todas técnicas cais que é uma coisa
extraordinária
[Aplausos]
mas quando isto acontecer não percebi
aquela pessoa e do quanto você pagos
teriam que ela tropeçar sob prévia dos
péssimos que pensa em uma coisa é que
elas representam e trabalham para
empresas que são a nossa presença no
mundo e podem ainda ser mais não vamos
querer via também dizem que não envia
aos 3 agora aos tv the office online
paulo estamos a receber na fabril é de
vamos ver vamos tentar ser um bocadinho
como holanda nunca nem como isso eu sei
que vocês pensam todo sistema mas isso é
impossível mas sei que não é não é
nós temos cá os veículos só temos que
ser verdadeiros connosco próprios
redescobrirem nós essa força que nos
levou ao mundo os tais cinco continentes
eu trabalho em três deus a qualquer lado
o vôo portuguesa dessa lei é sempre a
pessoa de contato e com muita freqüência
uma pessoa que surpreende então eu peço
que acredita nesta força que nós temos
penso que tal como antónio damásio disse
todos vocês conhecem e eu disse nós não
existimos por pensarmos existimos porque
sentimos sentido do nosso coração essa
força que vem conosco e há tantos
séculos nós vamos ser capazes não nos
reinventarmos porque isso não
necessitamos dia mas de apenas termos
técnicos somos e ao sermos isso somos
muito bons eu peço desculpa pelo
nacionalismo
mas quero dizer uma coisa tenho muito
orgulho em ser português e onde eu vou
eu triunfo e triunfou por umas horas
aula porque o falo português que é a
minha língua que eu amo do fundo do meu
coração eu não sou como a polícia grava
e eu sou uma pessoa que vou a qualquer
lado e sou capaz de triunfar porque sou
macho careca saiu mas tenho que vencer
evento porque veneno neste semestre para
ir em que ninguém acredita e eu estou lá
para provar
que somos capazes se vocês forem capazes
de fazer isso todos vocês só desta sala
sai uma força que é capaz de transformar
o mundo
obrigado
[Aplausos]